[Music]
in brainwash actress news and [ __ ]
submitted by towline bless you
Smallville actress aliceandmac is being
accused of recruiting sex slaves for
cult
where's Michael Rosenbaum oh we need him
no Lex Luthor come here Michael Rosen I
love that guy that guy's hilarious so
funny yeah this girl she was on
Smallville what's her name again her
name in the her character's name was
Chloe oh I don't know who the [ __ ] that
one is oh I don't know oh I know where
how she got our own show at something
else later on - mm-hmm don't what
bangbus she she's recruiting sex slaves
for a marketing team marketing cult
bangbus terrible why you do that finds a
sex slave - by the way that sex act
against your will and then you're just
fed like little and you just [ __ ] all
day well that sounds like you don't like
it then you don't like it you don't want
to but you have to yeah so Allison
sounds like a marriage right yes Allison
works with this multi-level marketing
company aka cult cult
so it's a pyramid scam it's a pyramid
scam and a sex cult so it's like a
division of the pyramid scam or
something to pick up a sex division yeah
so if this company it's called an X IBM
and apparently Allison has recruit has
recruited as many as 25 women into this
wave cult she's good at recruiting yeah
that's a pretty high number dude that's
a lot of people yeah not that it's good
to do it that's [ __ ] up but that's
hard work it's your job was for that
like 50 bucks a person or something
probably so I don't know different ways
yeah so then this division
the sex cult is called do s which stands
for dicks on standby it's believed to be
short for Dominus got a DLS here over
Dominus
they're already so currently offense for
Dominus obsequiously or iam which is
Latin for masturbating all the time
master over the slave women okay that's
mean
that yeah so apparently she was
brainwashed by the cult leader named
Keith Rainier brainier Rainier herb
Rainier she's so cute look at her dude
she's an evil [ __ ] the screenshot of a
video of her interviewing the cult
leader and in this video shook so skinny
like super super super skinny which is
apparently it which apparently is one of
the requirements to be in the sex cult
where like they limit how much you eat
and what time the day that you eat and
all this dude I just need to be a part
of this cult for like two months and I'm
good it's a good way yeah I heard cult
do that a lot no wonder he needed a
started you look that cults that get out
you know that look
they all have this cult leader signature
to look they all look like that his hair
is so smooth Gary they all have these
eyes that look nurturing but they're
like I want to [ __ ] your [ __ ] Bob
thanks Olie
yeah soulless nurturing eyes beautiful
part of these requirements also the
slaves are forcibly branded with
Allison's initials and Keith's initials
later look it fires like fire branding
like a cow like a cow yeah and then um
and so they're required to fast for 12
hours a day
oh I can't join this cult I'll tell you
those wait though yeah but I don't want
to do it that way I just go live it my
field
unhealthy way to lose weight yeah don't
do that how you gonna be horny when
you're so hungry yeah starve but it's
it's usually the cult leader that gets
all the perks and all his people are
well he's just eating sandwiches in
front of them from his dick he doesn't
look like he skips a meal where's the
nutritional value per tablespoon of
semen actually there's no protein and
semen semen is all starch oh yeah so
during this fast thing which is true
during this bad thing they're saying
that you googled it so for 12 hours a
day you have to fast and you can only
have water with lemon black tea with
lemon and honey or sparkling water
that's not bad have to take a cold
shower
why a cold shower because it builds
capacity for love through the tolerance
of pain oh and you also have to perform
a daily act to honor their master so
suck their dick out that's what I heard
something and they also must provide a
new piece of collateral on the first day
of every single month which can be
published if the slave decides to leave
the group or reveal the secret so these
this collateral is either nude photos
videotaped confessions to crimes or
financial information
what is the benefit for them to join the
cult you get brainwashed and then
Alison's recruiting them so it's like
this celebrity chick is really nice and
but what's the carrot that they're
hanging that makes girls go mmm
I'm gonna give up my rights for this
specific target certain people are very
vulnerable mentally already right but
then like they always have like a
benefit like Scientology is like yeah
you're gonna get Scientologist or some
[ __ ] yeah like how I'm gonna be saved
you're gonna be all know yeah whatever
like there's other ones called like
decisions or something like that like
love Brees answer horses whatever ever
heard of my [ __ ] life dude whatever
to be so the the NX IV and the mix all
apparent one of do s they claim to be a
self-help business help businesses yeah
yeah so there are so-called business
that has helped thousands of people
reach their potential potential I can't
I know something like this I know my
nose yes yeah so Allison she's 35 by the
way you guys are curious how old she is
tell us she she's believed to be
second-in-command of NX IBM um he has to
find sex partners for this leader dude
Rainier yeah Rainier and she also runs
40 miles a week and she keeps it top
down
Dushyant got [ __ ] on Casey nice that
though that thing is way more than that
[ __ ] [ __ ] so she's required to say
as skinny as possible
oh my god [ __ ] that this guy's trouble
am I
I don't know he does he get horny when
he goes to like Holocaust museums and
[ __ ] Jackie god that's so nasty so they
caught her right so these are all
allegations made towards her like were
there deserters how is this information
out yeah so it was actually the group's
former publicist oh so she brews she
blew the [ __ ] whistle on this [ __ ] oh
yeah Vance Frank Harlow he says I can't
stand this [ __ ] anymore so he was
getting his dick sucked he was a farm
publicist so maybe yeah after he got his
nut off now he wants to whistle blow I
don't know how that works Playboy or he
wasn't getting any at all and he got
jealous
that makes more sense II was getting
that scraggly [ __ ] is it all is it is
this all like Hollywood people that's
their targeting because like questions
one there is one woman that there
meaning that she has been recruited to
this and she's her name is India
Oxenberg and she's the daughter of a
dynasty actor named Catherine Oxenberg
so this is so apparently she has been
recruited to this sex cult and this is
her mom and she's an actor on finder
what a smile I don't recognize any of
those two I don't watch dynasty that's
so sad man yeah why do these things
happen in this world what appears why do
so many people feel so lost that they
gotta join something and give up
everything lost why does this happen can
you tell me why Tiffany why so strong me
why hey nothing but a sex call that's
just sad dude every time I hear about
this [ __ ] I just want to go in there and
[ __ ] save them but here's the thing
about cults I watch a lot of cult
documentaries they don't want saving
they think I'm the devil if I [ __ ]
break in there all right Joe to the
rescue they're like you don't need I
don't need helpful so you don't want to
be saved
she's like I don't don't give me that
meal you're trying to correct my belly
and I'm like ugh dude how do you how do
you get them out because what the number
one reason why people can't get out of
cults is all their friends and all those
years that they spent in there they
don't know how to function back like out
in the real world so all of the people
that they know all their friends
everybody like they don't want to leave
them cuz you know outside of the cult
[ __ ] they're having birthday parties
they're doing their wife their having
movie night they're doing normal [ __ ]
right like it's not cult day every day
so like I feel pretty sad that like if
you do it you got to burn the whole cult
down word and name association is so
interesting I hear the word Alison all I
do is remember
like for the past like 10 minutes I just
been thinking about this girl from high
school where she had the biggest titties
owners and her name was Alison and I'm
just like Oh Alex I remember Alison her
titties work mm-hmm you know I just read
an update on this it's crazy
apparently this is update now where
they're saying that Lana on Smallville
Lana's the character named Kristin Kreuk
allegedly brought Danish can you it
consists into the cult out of the cult
before it got really crazy also before
like it so it was like a before before
they had the dicks on standby a division
she was in it and then later on when
they set up Kristin Kreuk was the
hottest thing on earth to me dude she
was that good so it was it was um like a
pyramid scam just like a normal pyramid
scam and then it started morphing into
something more sexual and culty and
slave II know somehow that is the sad
[ __ ] man that's a crazy
[Music]
[Music]